I'm going to do them,
so I'll fight everybody.
This started with me calling out McGregor
and people were like, Oh,
that kid's crazy.
McGregor would kill him, da da.
And now it's like.
That fight could happen
in the next 24 months, 100%
and probably will and I will be in.
So people just like,
ah, seeing how serious I am about this
and changing the way they think about it
is that McGregor conversation happening
has been happening for for a while.
You know, we're talking to his team
and it makes sense.
You know, he wanted me to get more
fights under my belt
and build up my name,
build up my pay per view buys.
And that's exactly what I've done.
So, you know, we're coming to that
crossroad very shortly.